ce matin les salariés ont pris un énième
coup sur la tête
dans les allées de l'usiné de belfort
difficile de ne pas ressasser l'annnonce
de la nouvelles suppressions de postes
si elle était déjà dans les tuyaux
depuis plusieurs semaines son ampleur
marqué les esprits 240 des 800 postes
environ dans la branche steam sont
amenés à disparaître presque un tiers
des effectifs de l'entité on s'attendait
à quelque chose d'assez d'assez léger on
se retrouve avec un quelque chose qui
est massif et que j'aurais tendance à
dire trop tôt et trop gros parce qu'on a
encore beaucoup de travail avec les
projets nucléaires car l'incompréhension
se situe bien là la direction motive
cette restructuration par sa volonté de
se retirer du marché des centrales à
charbon
or parmi les 240 postes voués à
disparaître
seule une petite partie concerne
exclusivement ce secteur la plupart
travaillent aussi sur la partie
nucléaire
c'est une casse sociale encore une fois
sans précédent on peut pas laisser des
multinationales privées gérer des
activités essentielles pour la france
vous avez vous rendez compte l'énergie
c'est un bien commun on ne peut pas
laisser ça aux mains des financiers
c'est pas possible cette menace de
nouveau plan social survient alors que
ji et l'état sont en pleins pourparlers
pour le rachat d'une partie des actifs
un timing qui interroge selon ce
syndicaliste
general electric par ce chantage à
l'emploi
joujou quelque chose joue le bras de fer
peut-être c'est une hypothèse avec le
gouvernement prend le gouvernement
français dans le cadre d'une vente
de la branche nucléaire tous en
appellent à la responsabilité de l'état
et milite pour une intervention
d'urgence depuis 2015 plus de 1200
emplois ont été supprimés à belfort